main dans la main c'est devenu votre
spécialité de rendre fou votre papa et
cette fois-ci vous l'avez encore piéger
avec la complicité de votre femme vous
le dis vous avait simulé une opération
bénigne pour un problème de sinus sauf
que l'opération s'est pas passé comme
prévu et viennent vous voir à la
clinique et papa castaldi bas c'est un
cogneur
[Musique]
dès lors des mes bec bonjour je chantais
jours mam et ghazi chez les actrices de
la finale je cherche quelqu'un l'a bien
je vais vous installer en salles
d'attentes
je cite ce matin comme ça vous êtes
tranquilles house ko 5e est retenue
c'est castaldi d'un journaliste et ivan
son fils alors si benjamin le vent pour
toi c'est cool pourtant c'est pas cool
brand lui bonjour vous venez voir
monsieur castaldi
ouais donc tout s'est bien passé bien
mais suivez moi il encore les bandages
mais vous pouvez quand même leur art
school is a en tout cas l'opération
s'est super bien passé evans génial et
voilà les mots de paniquer
là il va pouvoir rentrer en discute un
peu gonflé chérie tu t'es vu ou pas dans
la ménagerie faut que tu te revient sans
des liens et après-demain on lève le
mans series va tu vas te regarder deux
[Musique]
îles et où médecins là à le médecin
vient juste de passer il m'a dit que
tout allait bien donc c'est bon il peut
rendre vraiment bon et rouge parle de
l'antenne comme ça deux jours et mon
amour tu fais pas une centaine de
coutume parle après le médecin appelé le
médecin
non je suis désolé madame je viens de
vous dire que en fait le médecin on peut
pas aller le voir je bon ok je vais pas
m'énerver deux rondes
jean pierre méthé ou jean-pierre qu'est
ce tu fais bien la paire il faut bien
malade est comme ça dans l'est un talent
comme ça comment tu dis donc toi
honnêtement la maintenant devant lui
comment tu te font maintenant on va
juste demandé aux médecins pourquoi il
est temps de vous dire en fait que le
médecin est passé
gentil jacques-de-romas je les gardais
vous allez voir se répéter non mais vous
êtes connu cas il faut commencer je
viens de vous dire que le médecin est
passé et qui a dit que tout allait bien
je l'entends je ne suis pas médecin je
suis en forme non non non je suis
infirmière du que je connais mon voile
un peu que vous êtes connu que faut
commencer
on va compenser les comédiens connus
c'est fait merci de suite merci bonnet
quand même mais vu que jerry touche par
touche ça ne touche pas et fait pas de
scandale mais dont vous connaissez votre
talent et menton des buck danny des
tracts seront en fait on va combler
mentalement qu'à une paire de couilles
qui a été greffée au menton s'est passé
pendant la campagne euros annoncé viser
bon tu l'as vu une fois c'est bon bah on
la mode c'est quoi il y aura bien une
âme au bon allez tout va bien je puis
vous mais moi je pense que tu as fait
les sinus et je pense que tu t'es fait
un peu plaisent et que tu t'es fait soit
le botox soit le petit livre que tu
voulais de fer à monsieur bonjour
monsieur le journal qui s'est lié au jeu
avant ils seront d'abord qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé mais je voudrais juste
comprendre pourquoi mon mari nick fry en
fait mais si tu te fait normal c'est une
réaction qu'elle reste opérationnelle
tout à fait normal ça peut durer entre
24 heures jusqu'à 72 heures ne vous
inquiétez pas tout s'est super bien
passé mais les bretons comme ce monsieur
c'est pas une réaction la ligue ont fait
écouter savez maintenant je fais ce
métier là et que vous êtes quand même
pas me dire comment elle veut faire
bachelot fait une dizaine par jour
tout le monde doit aller chercher notre
ami jean pierre
mais est ce qu'on n'a pas
droit jean pierre valade est comme ça
non je n'ai pas bien mais dès que le
médecin me laisse pas tout ça est le
médecin quand même aidé céline est ce
que tu vas à pléthore preuve de
souplesse mais aussi à des services sais
que j'ai fait du sinus
je comprends rien si ça se comprend mais
est-ce qu'il est malade et je lis ça a
été une jolie ce docteur est peut-être
venu le chef ne poussez pas vous dire
les années les autres gentiment ne
poussez pas boudé les uns et les autres
ok métal mais je ne l'avais pas vendu
nos centres de soins messieurs ce sont
des intermèdes confidentielles vous
n'avez pas de désir toulon va se calmer
les 100 jours je rentre je démens québec
et 6 sur 10 y aussi cette évidence est
rageant c'est normal je l'avais montré
la gueule et jazz le sujet
l'essentiel ici les chercheurs
responsables en plus il faut qu'on n'est
pas allé chercher un responsable et vous
revenez pas il voir dans la ridicule
voyez le chef de clinique et ne revenez
pas sans lui ok toutes ses missions et
dans le temps mais [ __ ] bouchard
on a peur d'un fameux trois mâts
elle pense que les menus motors alors
que c'est ma moins de tours je pense que
l'effet unis et la beauté non juste une
méprise en fait tom a fait une petite
inversion de quoi avec impatiente et la
moto c'est un cauchemar
[Musique]
oui avec bonjour docteur ce que c'est
moi je vous cherchez depuis tout à
l'heure je commande à je viens pour du
botox
[Applaudissements]
je joue ma carrière
qui vous remercier j'ai deux fois c'est
terminé maintenant on est 200 alors ça
c'est terminé on retrouve et on retrouve
à peine plus jamais ton car je suis
benjamin castaldi est énorme à jean
pierre camani aurore castaldi formidable
jean pierre castaldi non mais n'avait
est ce que vous voulez pour mémoire les
petites crises de colère des chauffeurs
on est passé comme ça du drame non c'est
vrai oui je voulais vraiment oui on
était moins naïve je vais débuter la
comaga camarades d'école à la beauté des
bottes de les garder il ya deux choses
et je laime pote papa je n'ai pas joué
mais je crois qu'ils ont pu assister
maintenant on se ruine pas fois plus
assister sur leur fera tout pour garder
ses plis coller à regarder les attendait
confidentielles
[Musique]
ici mais ça fait huit ans autant ici
franchement lève haut la main je vais te
l'a démonté jusqu'en février ta gueule
c'est le meilleur moment pour la caméra
quand c'est le meilleur génial isabelle
rhône avait un tournage une dizaine de
jours après dans la même clinique
les gens ne parlaient que de ça c'est
vrai de façon extrêmement grave et la
fée linafoot une trouille vous je vois
que vous avez plus d'infos sur la grande
race track sûreté pmp
[Applaudissements]